everybody has been clamoring about this
we got 800 000 super chats about Oliver
Anthony singer Oliver Anthony goes mega
viral with song rich men north of
Richmond John Rich offers to produce
record in the song Anthony Grieves the
separation between the average person in
America and the class of rich men north
of Richmond who want to have total
control of decisions in this country uh
it's an awesome song it's an absolutely
incredible performance just the guy with
his guitar he's it's amazing
Millennial says up and coming Virginia
country singer Oliver Anthony has gone
viral for the song He's got 2.3 million
views in the last two days and John Rich
has even offered to help him produce a
record dude this is some uplifting news
we talk about all this bad stuff all the
time ladies and men I want you to crack
open the beer hopefully not a bug Light
uh and grab some wings and have a good
time smile this is awesome
the song rich rich men north of Richmond
centers around a theme of struggling
working class American a struggle of the
struggling working class American being
pushed around by the political class
living in and around DC I've been
selling my soul working all day overtime
hours for BS pay so I can sit out here
and waste my life away drag back home
and drown my troubles away
in the song Anthony seems to grieve the
separation that has come between the
average person and these rich political
Elites taxes the state of wealth the
welfare state the death of young men in
the country are all topics the song
touches on
here's what I love about this
the song has a message
it is a positive message we like
through his talent
and his Merit it has been discovered and
gone viral online creating a real
opportunity John Rich legendary country
star is now stepping in so we've got
here a couple things one I want to
outright just say you get woke you go
broke Bud Light loses 400 million
dollars they're selling off their craft
Brands Disney loses 900 million dollars
and then factory worker guy out in the
boonies in Virginia puts together a song
and boom Superstar this is more of what
we want to see
we want to see people build culture
succeed making culture and we want to
supplant the the the the Twisted woke
culture that we've been seeing so shout
out Oliver Anthony the song's fantastic
and uh I don't know how you guys feel
I love this style of music and an artist
I'm already interested in who sort of
I'm coming was following him on
Instagram when I went to find this video
uh so I took that as a good sign I think
there's something to be said for
especially this like folksy Americana
sound to be talking about like something
that Real Americans are facing I mean we
can all uh harp on Prop songs about all
sounding the same and that's one of the
best things about this song it's
completely unique but also completely
relatable
I haven't listened to it so I have no
opinion wow Phil it's been out like a
day it's been like I thought you were
the musician I thought you were into
this stuff yeah we're supposed to have
resident Rockstar Phil be like I endorse
this song yeah I don't like acoustic
guitars no but but it's like I got to be
honest I'm not I'm not a country music
kind of guy that's not my jam but I am
absolutely all about
supporting people who are producing
cultural works that push back on woke
psychotic garbage and authoritarianism
and this hit the nail that head with a
hammer I don't care if a guy made a a
comic book a manga a video game or a
song gaining traction winning through
Merit regular working class guy hitting
it big time through through pure that's
what I love yeah you know what I heard
and I don't know Phil maybe you know
about this Justin Bieber you know how he
got to start uh was he a Disney kid well
YouTube I guess right oh YouTube but I
heard that was fake really I don't know
that's true I don't want to accuse the
guy of doing anything wrong I got no
beef
but what I heard so it's like he made a
YouTube video or something like that
where he's singing and then they're like
wow look how viral this is
I heard that it was like the managers
planned it we want to build this thing
around him where it's like he's a
natural star so they had him do the
video helped promote it I don't know if
that's true here's what I do know
Gangnam Style absolutely manufactured I
know for a fact because the Dude
actually I think to be honest the same
guy behind Justin Bieber who did this
but actually went to a speech where he
said they met with him in advance and
said how can we make this song because I
think this song can be very big in the
US like the Macarena this is amazing I'm
looking at the lyrics right now I've
been selling my soul working all day
overtime hours for pay I've
been living in Old this is this is great
I've heard I haven't heard I haven't
heard it yet but this we gotta help it
go viral we gotta help promote the the
culture that's where it's living in the
new world with an old soul I can relate
to that
I like it because like there are really
cool artists and people out there who
who are explicit like Maga Trump stuff
like that but what I like about this is
it's just really good art that speaks to
a part of culture that now more and more
gets overlooked because mainstream one
of the industries say you shouldn't talk
about those things did he go viral on
Twitter was it I think it was YouTube
okay and then and then on Twitter and
then he made a Twitter and I think I saw
it on Twitter first one of the things
you have to worry about when you're
trying to do something like this like
you don't want to be too on the nose and
I mean everyone knows what I'm talking
about like you've seen something where
you're just like all right I get what
you're trying to do but because you
didn't because you kind of don't have
your finger on the pulse where you ended
up being too literal and it sounds hokey
or whatever and you mean that song that
I'm working on called lizzo has insulin
resistance is to yes too much yeah I
think you shouldn't pulled back I think
you should pull back on that one I think
I I personally I think put the Big Mac
down is a better title but you know put
the Big Mac down I think people who
voted for Trump uh would relate to this
song it's the same demographic well the
thing is I like I haven't read the
lyrics but like
if it's if it's getting this kind of
response it makes me think that you
probably can relate to it without being
a trump voter that's the thing that that
you have to be able to like transcend
political ideas like one of these this
kid one time this is a little while ago
but some kid hit me up one day and he
was a big fan of All That Remains and he
was a very very far left kid and all
like all his interpretation of the stuff
that I was saying and All That Remains
lyrics is he got the idea that I was a
far leftist and it's like I'm not a
leftist at all there are a lot of a lot
of times where people on the right and
on the left are looking for the same
result and see the same problems they
just have a different means to go to
solve it and I think that you try to
identify things that are human without
sounding too much like your one
political perspective or the other or at
least that's what I think is is the best
way to to get people onto yourself I
think there's working class on both
sides yeah exactly it's it's easy to be
well not easy I don't want to take
anything away from people that do this
it's one thing to be like I'm a Maga guy
I'm the mag like Bryson the gray The
Bryson gray the mega rapper cool awesome
that's his deal he's a Maga guy cool but
it's also cool to be able to be like yo
I can hang out with the Maga people and
I can also hang out with the people that
aren't Mega people you know what I mean
that's one of the things I like with
this this idea like the Richmond north
of Richmond like that's everybody in DC
that's not a political party and that
means that there actually is a lot of
unity among people outside of you know
like Working Class People of either uh
political leaning and this is an example
of that we just think of it as the
working class guys are all completely
Maga all the time because we assume All
City people we have a resident New York
City Republican uh Among Us right now
but like there are there is discrepancy
and I think the idea that the political
Elite is actually the one making all
decisions is uh a unifying idea wow so I
gotta I'm gonna make an All That Remains
cover band called All That Remains Maga
cool and we're going to change all the
lyrics to be about supporting Trump yeah
absolutely are these lyrics to his song
yeah these are amazing it looks like
he's calling out lizzo here well God if
you're five foot three you're 300 pounds
taxes ought not to pay for your bags of
fudge rounds I know their news came out
today that they dropped lizzo in
consideration for the Super Bowl well
yeah
I don't know
but maybe he's uh vying for a spot dude
maybe we shouldn't have the what was it
when they MTV or whatever where they had
the Giant bad on stage and those three
fat women were like engaging in
simulated adult activities was that WAP
I don't know but I'm like maybe we have
this guy on stage and that's the message
we want to leave that sounds like a
direct challenge to lizzo right there
this like this when uh when you were
away we had Carter on and we talked
about uh someone called in uh Tim Cass
uh member who said you know I'm trying
to get into music and I don't really
write political stuff but I could it's
trying to talk to Carter Banks our music
producer about it and we were talking
about that uh your alternative this like
folksy country stuff is really popular
right now and I think this person is
talented like when I was scrolling
through his Instagram he's been making
music for a while he obviously has
picked up on something that needs to be
said and he's in a genre that's done
well and I think it's cool to see
someone get this kind of recognition
because it's art as opposed to just a
political campaign you know what I mean
I mean the culture right now is so
starved for a good quality original
authentic content that obviously this
would fill a void for all art not just
music but yeah I agree with you Unity
baby Unity I think you said it best
earlier I think why don't we just bring
everybody from the right and left come
together and we just come because the
left doesn't want to come together
I was like Ian's not here tonight I was
like Robbie can be that hippie Crystal
I'm just saying you know it's all come
together and let's take down the
establishments
yeah so here here's here's what we end
up seeing you get people like vosh who
say the right is inherently
authoritarian which literally makes no
sense because the full political Compass
has Libertarians on both both sides the
quote unquote right as it's typically
defined recognizes that the left has
Libertarians and the right as
Libertarians and they scale up in very
different ways but the left views it
entirely as
you are on the right you are bad no
matter what to the point where we have
people
come into this show and defend books
like this book is gay and genderqueer
the sexually explicit books given to
kids and I'm like you're just agreeing
with that because the left tribally
agrees with that the the right tends to
be an amalgam of various World Views the
left tends to be rigid and the easiest
way to explain it Donald Trump
anti-establishment right I don't think
anybody would describe Trump as
establishment now they may try to as a
smear
leftists and I don't mean liberals I
mean leftists advocated for voting for
neo-liberal corporate candidate Joe
Biden
prominent socialist and communist person
as on YouTube with millions of followers
said you have to vote for Joe Biden me I
I don't like any of them because I'd
probably vote libertarian before
anything else didn't vote for Trump in
the first time around saw what he was
doing second time around no new Wars and
I said well I'm not a republican but
Trump has really gotten the the Deep
State the the bureaucratic system coming
after the corporate establishment so I'm
going to vote for this guy for these
reasons the left then said that's
fascist and authoritarian and you're the
problem and I'm like bro you're the
people marching around with slogans that
Walmart puts up in their building right
like you are you are Marching along at
the slogans of the US Army and Amazon
and Pfizer they are the establishment
now there are people on the left in
terms of the political spectrum that are
anti-establishment few and far between
but we're like Jimmy Dore Jimmy Dore is
economically left and anti-establishment
so we we love the guy he's fantastic
we're big fans thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time